Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning, supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
So on today's episode, we have
Professor Michael Mahoney, who
is one of the world's leading
experts on machine learning,
mathematics, and computer
science.
He's also somebody who I've got
to know over the past year and
has been a great help in
understanding this space.
He's among other things, an
Amazon scholar.
So we've managed to work
together a little bit.
And hopefully, as you can tell
from this episode, he's a a
really nice guy and has a great
sense of humor and such an
intelligent person.
Where do I start to talk about
what he's done?
Well, he's a professor at UC
Berkeley in the Department of
Statistics, but he's also at
Lawrence Berkeley National Lab.
And as I mentioned, he's also an
Amazon scholar and, and has a
few more hats as well.
He, if you look at his Google
Scholar, which for a lot of
academics is a way of, you know,
getting a look at what they've
done, he has some pretty
impressive statistics.
And one that sort of comes to
mind, not only does he have more
than 36,000 citations, which,
which is a lot, his h-index is
84, which is very high.
But what's more impressive is,
and again, this is probably
going into the details, but it
makes a difference.
If you go on Google Scholar and
you look at the number of
citations, his is exponentially
growing.
So not only does he have more
than, you know, 30,000
citations, H&X of 84, which is
already in the very high, sort
of top 1% or probably even
higher, it is increasing like
this, which basically shows that
his research is becoming ever
more relevant every single year.
It's not plateauing or going
down.
That's actually very impressive
and that shows why he is so
highly regarded because his work
is really cutting edge.
There are many, I think it's
fair to say that because he has
that mathematics background and
that computer science
background, he's put his hand to
many different things.
But one thing maybe relevant for
the listeners or viewers of this
podcast is a paper he did with
some colleagues on
characterizing possible failure
modes in physics informed neural
networks.
And this is, you hear many
people talk about pins, physics,
informed neural networks.
And so they did a great paper a
couple of years ago looking at
some places where it may not do
so well.
We talk actually about that in
the podcast.
We go through some of the themes
I've discussed with other
leading ML experts.
And we talk about, for example,
his opinion on, you know, do you
really need to include the
physics in this AI for science
regime or is it good enough just
to use data?
We discussed this at length.
And we also get into the topic
of foundational models for
science, something that he's
actually really being a leading
voice on.
He's given numerous keynotes,
important seminars, and
published papers in this area.
So we have a good debate about
that.
But we actually start off the
conversation talking about
something he's also very well
known for, which is randomized
linear numerical algebra, which
is quite a complex topic, to be,
to be completely honest.
And I don't think we got to the
bottom of it in this short talk,
but it really shows that some of
his work from the pure math side
or pure math side is coming
through and being relevant as we
increasingly look towards lower
precision methods and ways of
doing mathematical tricks to try
and improve the speed of many
linear solvers, which are
common, of course in many, many
fields of science, including
CFD.
We also talk about his general
opinions or advice for people
looking to move between academia
and industry.
Just general career advice,
something he's well placed given
that he has an incredible
academic record, but he's also
very close to industry and sort
of industrial applications as
well.
An hour or an hour and a bit is
not really enough to go through
all of this, but I, I certainly
learnt a lot and I really
enjoyed talking to him like I do
every time I speak to him.
And I hope you'll, you'll find
the same thing.
I will add some links if you're
watching this on YouTube because
again, he's published so many
papers and done so many great
talks that I really want you
after watching this, listening
this to go to his website and
and look through all of those.
And obviously if you are
watching this on YouTube, you
may prefer to listen to it.
Some people don't realise that
these podcasts are in video form
and YouTube, but they're also on
Spotify and Apple for audio and
vice versa.
If you normally listen to this
and you didn't realise there's a
full video version, you can go
to YouTube.
So yeah, I hope you enjoy this
conversation with Professor
Michael Mahoney.
One topic that you mentioned to
me when we were chatting in the
past that I was fascinated by,
but if I'm being completely
honest, I didn't fully
understand.
So it's good for my purpose and
for everybody else was around
the randomized linear algebra.
What exactly?
For people who don't know what,
what is it and why is this
becoming even mentioned on a
Netflix show?
So that yeah.
So that's, this was a sign of
success when it was finally
mentioned on a net no, the
Lincoln Lawyer a couple of years
ago, someone sent it to me and
it was mentioned in in one of
the courtroom scenes.
So randomized linear algebra,
randomized numerical linear
algebra is basically an area
that uses randomness as an
algorithmic resource to solve
linear algebra problems.
A lot, a lot of linear algebra
problems are under the hood,
whether you're doing machine
learning or scientific
computing, they manifest
themselves in different ways.
So the exact questions and
numerical issues and so on are,
are different in those areas.
And that's the source of maybe
tension in the area, but also
synergy and, and, and, and, you
know, part of the reason a lot
of people are interested in it
because it, it holds the
potential to solve a lot of
problems people look at, But
it's, it's solving core linear
algebra problems and, and linear
algebra ones appear in a lot of
places.
If you're solving partial
differential equations, it's,
you know, linear operators or
iterated former linear operators
appear.
If you're solving machine
learning, you may be interested
in support vector machines or
ensembling methods or these days
deep neural networks.
And so matrix multiplications
are at the core of a lot of that
stuff.
So very core linear algebra
problems.
I think historically the way
people thought about the
relationship between linear
algebra and and randomness or
noise was that there's
randomness and noise in the
world, meaning the data you
measure, think of least squares
and it's your job to clean it
up.
And then you call a linear
algebra problem least squares or
low rank approximation.
And you get more or less a
deterministic answer and you get
more or less the exact answer.
I mean, and I say exact and
scare and scare quotes because
there's numerical issues and you
can't represent sqrt 2 on a
computer, but you know, in so
far as machine precision is
exact and you get an exact
deterministic answer.
And for a lot of things that's
just overkill.
And so you can use randomness as
an algorithmic resource, meaning
inside the algorithm to speed up
computation.
And this may be most notable
historically, like in Monte
Carlo or Markov Chain Monte
Carlo, where you run simulations
of of fluid dynamics.
I mean, the Metropolis algorithm
was developed in that context,
but this is for core numerical
linear algebra problems.
And so most people, if they're
running computations, sit on top
of Glass and LA Pack and, and,
and related software.
And if you're calling Python,
you're calling something else,
you're calling something that's
calling something that's calling
them typically.
And so these are core libraries.
And so the question is, can you,
you know, use good theory from
randomness and measure
concentration and high
dimensional probability to
improve those algorithms or
improve, you know, variance of
those algorithms?
The short answer is that you
can.
So how?
But so how does it work in
practice then?
So if I'm sold in APDE and I'm
normally using some sort of
linear algebra library and it
takes me this time or this
amount of flops or this compute,
how is it that the randomness
reduces that?
Yeah, I mean, when you're
solving APDE, you're typically
solving it for a particular
application and you're calling
certain core linear algebraic
primitives in in one way or
another.
So for example, if you're
solving it with a splitting
method or predictor corrector
method, or you're solving a
finite element or finite volume
or you're solving a second order
optimization to as a piece of
that PDE solver.
These have least squares, you
know, linear solves things like
this under the hood.
So typically you're improving
those.
You could, you could improve the
modeling setup for the PDE also.
But but you know, you could, you
could try and solve the, you
know, the improve the core
primitive.
So take least squares as an
example, a low rank
approximation.
A common motif in in a lot of
these algorithms is you have the
data and you want to solve the
least squares of the low rank
problem.
And you could solve it exactly
machine precision or whatever.
But you might want to on the
other hand, get what they call a
sketch of the of the data, which
is roughly a small number of
data points.
It could be a small number of
actual data points, or it could
be what they call a random
projection.
And if you're familiar with like
if you feel signal processing
and electrical engineering and,
and physics, think of this as
like a randomized version of a,
of a Fourier transform.
So it takes some signal that
that might be localized in space
and, and spreads it out
everywhere.
But you don't need this to be a
physical space.
This is just a linear algebraic
problem.
And so you have, you know, you
have columns and rows, so you
could select the important
columns or rows, or you could do
this random projection, which is
essentially a, a basically a
random type rotation that
spreads the information out and
then sample uniformly in that
rotated space.
And so you take this sketch and
you can do one of a couple
things that so some communities,
the more theoretically inclined
communities want to take that
sketch and solve the sub problem
exactly.
And there's a range of
theoretical work that says the
solution to the exact, the exact
solution to that sub problem
computed any which way.
A traditional solver or
something else is epsilon close
to the exact solution to the
original problem if you set
things up right.
Now, in a lot of cases that is
sort of course because you
can't.
It's hard to get machine
precision just by drawing a
sample and solving the sub
problem unless you take a huge
number of samples, just because
Monte Carlo methods tend to
converge slowly as a function of
the error parameter.
So you could take that, you
know, low quality, low
precision, but not trivially bad
solution and ask yourself what
is a preconditioner?
And by preconditioner I just
mean a preconditioner for APDE
solver or or least squares or a
linear solver.
And a preconditioner is
basically a low quality solution
that you refine.
So you can actually take this
preconditioner that the that
this is a sketch.
The theoretically inclined
people just say good, done M
epsilon good.
And you can say, now I'm going
to take that epsilon good where
epsilon is .1 and just use any
of a range of traditional
iterative solvers and drive that
epsilon down to 10 to the -8 or
10 to the -16.
And, and just like most
preconditioners, if, if the cost
to construct it is less than the
cost to, you know, the cost to
construct it plus iterate is
less than you know, the, the
algorithm you're competing with,
you win.
And it's a good preconditioner.
So there's a range of ways
people solve it that way.
So those are called sketch and
solve and sketch and
precondition, respectively.
Increasingly for machine
learning applications that want
medium precision, also relevant
for scientific computing when
you're interested in low
precision data representations,
you know, going to half or
quarter precision, which is, is
increasingly seen in hardware.
There's a more subtle interplay
where you can get the solution
and then you can iterate it and
get a second sketch and toggle
back and forth.
And if you set the parameters
differently, you can get
intermediate solutions 10 to the
-210 to the -410 to the -6
quality.
So there's a range of ways you
can use the sketches, but
roughly the idea is you get most
of the information in the sketch
and and solve it or do something
with it.
And is there any, you know,
orders of magnitude of the
savings that you could get?
You know, if I'm doing a Nabia
Stokes solver or solving some
neural net using these
randomized, you know, numerical
linear algebra versus a blast
rolling back, Are we talking,
you know, a 10% saving?
Is it an order of magnitude or
is it still under research?
And so it's not delivering the
full yet.
Yeah.
I mean, I think the question of
of how well you'd improve upon
something depends strongly on
what your baseline is.
And if you feed this into a big
PD solver, there's a lot of
moving parts and you're
competing with very mature code
and they're doing a little bit
better or even a lot better on a
solver may or may not matter for
the downstream use case that
that the scientist that is
looking at the PD solver is
interested in roll gold to the
other extreme.
And you want to say, I want to
compete with blast or a late
pack.
These are extremely optimized
pieces of code and it's, you
know, it's hard to beat them.
So one of the big successes in
the area was with blend and
pick.
And then soon after that was LSR
and blend and pick, which said
we wanted to ask whether these
randomized sketches, you know,
not in theory, not Big O
notation, not whatever can they
beat LA pack Because this is not
boutique code you have or I have
or a solver that you don't share
with the community.
So well, this is something
that's been stress test for
decades.
And the answer is yes.
I mean, basically on any tall
dense matrix, you can beat LA
pack with these techniques.
You got to set parameters right
and be a little bit careful.
But, but the short answer is
yes, how much you improve it by
depends on the aspect ratio and
depends on properties of of the
matrix.
But think of it as ballpark 2 to
10.
Now this was back in 2010 and so
a lot's changed the since then,
in particular in the hardware
landscape with respect to GP us
and hardware heterogeneity and
the Sun sending of Moore's law
and Dennard scaling and these
sorts of things.
And so it is the case that you
know, you can be a factor of 10
better.
Similarly in in in low rank type
approximations.
I think the the the way
scientists versus machine
learners use low rank
approximations is very
different.
Scientists tend to say low rank
means you know 99% of the
Frobenius norm, meaning 99.9% of
the Frobenius norm and 99.99 I
mean basically the whole matrix.
When machine learners say low
rank, they mean sorry, sorry,
the spectral norm.
When machine learners say low
rank, they mean, you know, 50%
of the Frobenius norm, in which
case, you know, you lose a lot
of information, but you might
iterate and and do something
better.
So think of sort of scaling laws
and the neural scaling context
with, with neural networks.
And so the way you'd use those
low rank algorithms and feed
this them into other solvers
would be very different.
And then that would lead to very
different levels of improvement.
And so I think that's largely
open.
And then with the memory wall
that you're increasingly seeing
in, in general, but most
egregiously in the machine
learning applications, one of
the big wins and it's just
starting to be explored for the
randomized techniques is
basically improving the memory
properties.
And so this could be just
reordering algorithms in the
sense of communication, avoiding
linear algebra could be much
broader because the randomness
sort of decouples things, makes
it easier to paralyze certain
sorts of computations.
And so you see much bigger than
factors of 2 or 10 improvement
there.
But then again the baselines
changing year to year as as as
people explore different
representations and and low
precision and intermediate
precision and stuff.
Interesting, so how was it
mentioned in Netflix then going
back to the former?
Well, the particular I, I think
so, I'm not a movie star or a
movie producer, but I, I have a
sense that they, they want to,
I, I mentioned this to someone
and they said, you know what
that means?
They tried to take the most
exotic thing that wouldn't make
sense to anyone and, and, and,
and cited it.
So the context was I, I think it
was early on and the, the, the
main character, who was this,
the attorney needed to represent
someone and the person had to
get out of, of, of whatever they
were charged with, which was not
a, a, you know, relatively minor
thing, but it was the 10th time
they did it.
And so they, the, the, the
Lincoln lawyer said, why do you
need to get out?
And they said, I have a defense
on Thursday.
I need to get out.
And they asked what's the,
what's the topic?
And they said randomization and
numerical in your algebra.
So that was the context of how
it was mentioned there.
I wonder how they found that
out.
I wouldn't know how they
actually.
Yeah, I don't know.
They they, they, they didn't
call me up.
So they must have had someone in
movie producer land or something
that did did a Google search on
on something exotic and came
across.
It that's fine.
Yeah.
That's like reminds me of the
Did you ever like Star Trek?
Yeah, I used to see if there's a
bifurcation which maybe would
get us in into a separate
discussion whether you like the
original version or the the
second version.
But then there was this
explosion of different,
different versions of it.
Yeah, I was more the next
generation person, but I the
reason I mention it is it was
often whenever they wanted to
explain how they were breaking
the laws of physics, some
stupidly complicated phrase was
used.
And I'm sure it exists somewhere
and it just reminds me of that,
you know, explanation of how
they're exceeding the warp
drive.
Oh, it's because the something
something.
Yeah.
So I think it was a little bit
like that.
I mean, I, I think it's a sign
of the times that what they're
citing is not warp Dr. and
quantum gravity, but
randomization numerical.
This is a core statement about
how areas are progressing and so
on.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
So maybe one of the topics would
be good to chat with you about,
and it's definitely a hot topic
at the moment, is the the
foundational models for science.
I've seen quite different
viewpoints.
There's one argument that is,
well, large language models take
all this data from the Internet.
They train and they're
remarkably good at doing what
they do.
What about if we could do it for
scientific disciplines?
Wouldn't we be able to just, you
know, ask her a prompt to go and
simulate me a plane or, or, or
do something?
And then there's the the other
Ave., which seems to be more the
replacing simulation tools or
augmenting simulation tools like
graph cast or forecast net or,
you know, these sort of Seminole
pieces of work that have come
out, but they were for very,
they had to be trained, you
know, for something.
Where do you see this?
Where do you see this going?
Are foundational models
possible?
Is it we just don't have enough
data?
This is a big topic.
So yeah, I'm not sure how we
want to start it.
I mean, we're in the middle of
this fray and I guess that's why
we were asking about this.
And I should start off with
saying I don't know what a
foundation model is.
Actually.
I know what different people say
a foundation model is and, and
it means very different things
to to different communities.
And so I think articulating that
a little bit helps articulate
some of the possible directions
and some of the questions you're
asking.
I mean, I think one way to think
about a lot of these machine
learning methods and it's
highlighted particularly cleanly
with these foundation models is
machine learning methods.
And in particular, these
foundation models are, they're
an infrastructure, right?
The, the, the, the Stanford
report said, call it foundation
models, not foundational models,
because it's a foundation in
which you build things and as
and as opposed to a half dozen
other terms they could have
used.
Now, whether that's right or
not, I mean, but that, that's
what they said.
And so since then people have
said, well, it has to be this
big and that big and, and
whatever.
And, and then people want to get
a foundation model, not for all
of science, but for area A&B&C
and sub area D&E&F and get finer
and finer granularity.
So in a sense it's, it's a it's
a term.
And, and if you ask people, most
people using it what it means,
they sort of will acknowledge
that, that they don't know.
And it's not a standard
definition.
I think probably the best way to
think about it is it's, it's,
it's infrastructure, it's a
foundation what you build
things.
And so the computer's
infrastructure, I mean, you can
do different things with the
computer than you can do with
pencil and paper.
And so it wasn't obvious the way
computer science, even before it
existed, would evolve.
And at one point, post World War
2, the US thought they'd need 5
computers and that would be it.
And then it would solve all the
nation's needs, right?
So it evolved in ways different
than expected.
And it involved in particular
because it, it could complement
what people did.
I mean, you could ask different
scientific questions than you
could with pencil and paper and
you could ask different
engineering questions than you
could.
I mean, now you can simulate
whole things and, and the very,
very last step is building it,
right.
But in addition, you could do
lots of other things that were
driven by industry.
And, and so there's a
bifurcation in the area whether
you're doing more numerical
things that are continuous or
whether you're doing discrete
things that, that, that are not
continuous that were driven
largely cited by business needs.
So I think the, the right way to
think about this is it's that
sort of infrastructure and it's
tied to the data more closely
than than, you know, database
systems because the foundation
models have information cooked
into them.
And so it wasn't obvious some
number of years ago that just
with language you, you could do
what you know, has caught the
popular attention in the last
couple of years.
So I think so to anyone who says
that confidently, you, you can
or you can't with science, I
mean, probably you can't say
that they're sort of reliably
saying what what will hold for
the future 'cause I think it's
not at all.
I think it's not all clear for
two reasons.
One, there's certain technical
things that really do matter.
I mean that that are different
about scientific data than, you
know, language and, and vision
data.
And then there's just very
different cultural, there's very
different cultural things.
I think every scientist thinks
that their data is special and
unique just like they think that
they're special and unique.
M LS taught you anything.
These algorithms can predict
what movie you'll watch and what
stuff you'll buy better than you
can.
And so you're maybe slightly
less unique, you know, than than
you thought in some sense.
And so I think there's a
question, you know, what does
foundation model mean and how
can it be used so narrowly?
You know, I have a big model I
can train it in in domain A
domain A could be weather and
climate have gotten attention,
but it could be fluid dynamics.
It could be something else about
stylist formation.
It could be properties and
materials and doing density
functional theory and so on.
And then there's a question
about whether you could maybe
learn broad based models that
cut across domains, which would
of course be the more
interesting thing.
So there's something Kronos
said, I was involved with the
AWS people that sort of says, I,
I don't want to be the best at
at the most extreme things.
I don't want to be the 1% that's
predicting the most extreme
things I want to be.
I want to do as well as as the
majority of users for for time
series analysis and oversimplify
the story.
I mean, time series is a
complicated area clearly of
interest in a lot of cases, but
it's it's a little bit, you
know, you got to be careful
about off by 1 errors and a
range of other technical things.
And what that says basically is
take a language model, language
model structure with a bunch of
time series and just mean center
it and variance normalize it.
So just do the simplest possible
things you could and you got to
do some data augmentation stuff
and boom, you know, you do sort
of comparably and, and better
than a a wide range of public
benchmarks.
Now, the public benchmarks are
not extraordinarily high because
a lot of time series data is
valuable and so companies tend
not to release it.
But but the fact that you can do
that just by sort of variance
normalizing and and mean
centering is is, you know, not
obvious and sort of interesting.
It turns out sort of on a
separate thread that you could
say, could I do well compared to
the 1%, you know, the most
extreme things and, and the the
answers that you can there too.
You got to use different
techniques than you do there.
And so that leads to questions
as to whether you could have a
foundation model for sort of a
broad swaths of, of time series
and forecasting analysis.
And so, as you know, I said, I'm
an Amazon scholar working with
the Scott team and we're looking
at that there.
And one of the interesting
things I think about there, if
you look at the details of the
model, not the chronos, but some
other things, why would you
expect that article scraped from
Wikipedia, you know, public,
publicly available language
models?
What would, why would that allow
you to do better job predicting
dog food demand?
You know, I mean, it's not
obvious they have anything to do
with anything.
You know, it turns out, I
suspect the hypothesis is that
the text, the linguistic
structure that you're learning
from the Wikipedia articles is
strongly related to sequence to
sequence modeling, which, you
know, if you think of 1
dimension as a metric space,
it's a very, very special metric
space, a very specially
structured metric space.
And so you can learn not just
recent information and not just
low frequency information over
the past, but maybe in
information at different scales.
Because, you know, sometimes
articles in text refer back 10
words or 100 words or 1000 words
or 10,000 words.
So you can learn these sort of
heavy tailed sort of structures
and that gives you a better set
of basis functions to learn dog
food demand or whatever else.
So in a sense, these, the
language models give you better
embeddings, you know, 4A
analysis and Laplace transforms
and, and these sort of things
are great for pencil and paper.
They're all developed in the
1800s, right?
These are data-driven embeddings
that are good if you have
computers and and data not
necessary for pencil and paper,
but they're good for that.
And so that leads you to the
question about if, if I'm really
careful about doing foundation
model work in science, what do I
need to worry about?
It's not the details of this PDE
or that PDE.
It might be that I want to
reproduce what happens in the
natural language processing the
NLP models, which is roughly
scale model and data and
compute.
So none of them saturate.
That's very different than the
usual strong scaling and weak
scaling and high performance
computing.
I want to change the amount of
data I'm putting in.
I want to change the size of the
model.
I want to change the size as it
computes.
So none of them saturate and,
and the conjecture would be that
if if any of them saturate, it's
going to be harder to do
transfer learning.
So you really need the non
saturation and you do that one
way with NLP, natural language
processing and CV computer
vision.
But an NLP and CV, there's much
weaker control you have and that
you need on the spatiotemporal
geometry than PD ES, right?
Is, is, you know, PD ES, if
you're below a nice a Mach
transition or some other
physical transition, things are
sort of smooth.
If you're above it, things are
very messy.
Dealing with that transition is
hard and people spend their
whole careers dealing with that.
So can you come up with data
generation or tokenization
mechanisms that that respect the
spatio temporal properties?
So I think if you're going to
have a foundation model that
applies across a raw broad range
of sciences that's trained on
weather and, and, and climate
and, and simulations of
different grid structure from
the machine learning
perspective, it's not so
different than satellite data
from satellites looking down,
you know, it's a different grid
and it's an image.
And then you say, how does that
couple with the spatiotemporal
properties?
So I think if, if you want to
deliver on the promise in the
same way is, is the is computer
science had to work out a range
of numerical methods to really
match and beat state-of-the-art,
you're going to have to do a
similar thing here.
And so partly depends on these
technical issues, but partly
depends on cultural issues.
But how much do you think?
I mean you raised the what
percent versus the 50%?
I guess that is one argument as
well, which is how close does it
need to be to machine accuracy
to be useful.
You could argue that any of
these large language models, the
way that most people use them,
there is still a correction you
need to add.
You don't typically ask it to do
something right, document and
literally take it word for word.
You usually go in and go.
That's, that's remarkably close,
but I'm still going to go and
fix it.
Or it writes you a Python code.
It's unusual, isn't it, that
it's perfect.
There's usually something you
have to correct.
So I guess with the science
side, maybe the argument is how
close does it need to be to be
useful And the cost of getting
the incremental increase in
accuracy, you know, is it, is
there a like a trade off where
you need so much more?
Data, I mean, again, I think the
best analogy is look at the
history of computer science and
how that of all that, I think, I
think framing the question to
say how close does it need to be
to be useful?
You're already framing it in a
way that that makes certain one
group comfortable, the numerical
analysts and the PD people that
frame a question a certain way.
That's not how people would have
framed the question before.
I mean that, you know, before
you had, you know, represented
continuous numbers on, on a
computer discreetly take a step
back and say, I want to solve a
certain problem.
And, and the question is now
that I have very different trade
off in terms of compute versus
data and I have this new
infrastructure that's language
models.
Can I ask a different question
and, and, and push the science
for it?
I mean, so in, for example, in,
in chemistry historically, but
also nucleus physics and, and in
fluid mechanics, there's this
notion of a semi empirical
theory, which is a theory sort
of derived, you know, it's not
just curve fitting, it's derived
from an underlying more
fundamental theory, maybe
phenomenologically with
parameters that are then fit
empirically or semi empirically.
And So what you need there is
not the theory to be right, but
sort of right enough at the
level of in the, in the
chemistry is chemical accuracy,
which is, is however many
kilovolts or whatever depends on
the reaction you're interested
in so on.
And so certain methods that
maybe were more principled were
a bit too course for that.
And other methods, when you
combined it with other
techniques achieved chemical
accuracy.
And so none of them were low
enough in the stack that you
they were better QR codes for QR
from, from linear algebra.
But they solved the downstream
problem at that level of
actually, probably what you'd
see here is that right?
So it's, it's probably not going
to be so successful to say I
want to get 10 to the -16 or 10
to the -2 of my large language
model, but but a foundation
model for science and need not
be an LLM.
It, it, it, you could be
literally learning the
embeddings from a range of PD
ES.
You could, you could train to
PDS of different types.
And you could say, I want to
port if I, if I know the basics
of hyperbolic and parabolic.
And I know that in the transport
equation, this can enter in a
certain way.
And you have nonlinearities and
certain types of forcing
functions, you know, model each
of those and and solve each of
the components separately.
So I think the question is,
what's the right level of
abstraction to do that?
And, and one of the modalities
you could use is language, but
of course you could use image or
PD ES or simulations, any of a
range of things.
So I think in the context of, of
scientific problems that the
foundation model need not be an
LLM based.
I mean, there's some people are
pushing that, I think, but but
it certainly need not be LLM
based.
We just query the model and say,
you know, tell me what to look
for, the top quark or whatever.
Well that that's the bit maybe
you brought up would be
interesting to explore.
There is, AI would say, a
relatively fierce or contested
argument around physics informed
or physics in it versus
data-driven.
Where do you sit on that, on the
argument?
Do you, do you?
Does the model need to
implicitly have some of the
boundary conditions, some
awareness of continuity of
energy?
Or is it good enough just to
give it so much data that it
essentially learns those laws by
itself?
Yeah, I mean, I, I think you
could ask the same question
about in natural language
processing, computer vision does
did you just, I mean, there's a,
there's a common story people
tell which is just get more data
and everything works.
But that ignores the fact as you
know, that a lot of companies
and universities, a lot of
people have put a lot of
resources into NLP and CV to try
and figure out how to make it
work.
And you know, convolutions
convolve things, they spread
stuff out.
You know, if you have an image
in 2D that may make sense, you
might want to average over
nearby things.
But if there's, if there's a
sharp corner like, you know, the
shirt against the background
wall in this picture in my of
me, you may smudge stuff out.
And so there's a range of ways
to try and sort of deal with
that.
That's core structure.
The 2D structure that you're
trying to average over is very
different than sequence to
sequence learning.
That's also much more discreet
in, in natural language
processing.
So it's not like computer vision
or natural language processing,
just learn stuff.
You gave it very particular
architectures that had very
particular adaptive biases and
then you're careful about the
data and, and trying to get gobs
of it and, and then then it
worked.
So I think if you, you know,
you'd have to follow the same
path here.
You can't just take an existing
architecture and press a button
and hope it works.
I mean, time series, forecasting
space, you temporal modelling,
these sorts of things will have
to be, you have to figure that
out, how to do that.
So I think the question, I mean,
some people, you know, I think
are, and, and maybe sometimes
people that have a vested
interest in, in moving forward
or not.
I mean, some people say, you
know, just ignore everything,
let the data do it all.
Some people say, Oh, you'll
never match what I can do with
my careful PD solver.
I mean, I think that's neither
of those questions is the right
one.
I mean, the question is, given
the fact that there's an
infrastructure of code and
experience numerically, but but
you're also at a very different
place.
You've been sitting on top of
certain essentially hardware
and, and, and linear algebraic
advances.
I mean, for years, for decades.
People working on PDS call
certain linear algebra libraries
and have essentially had not to
pay the technical debt
associated with the fairly high
level of of complexity with
developing new linear algebra
because just wait a year or two
and the machines are faster.
And so if, if, if that's not the
case, you're going to have to
start thinking a little bit more
carefully about the underlying
linear algebraic computations.
Maybe there's different
trade-offs points in the space
and maybe bring something else
to bear.
You know, a model that has
learned certain course type
functions of one dimension, say
from the language model that I
alluded to before that aren't
Fourier modes or aren't Laplace
modes or aren't something else
like that that they're more
familiar with, learn a different
grid type discretization.
So I think the real challenge in
delivering on the promise of all
this stuff is figuring out what
the right way to combine those
two.
So you can imagine rather than
just writing down a physics
informed loss and pressing a
button saying, well, the way
people actually would solve this
is to have some sort of
splitting method and deal with
the two types of physical things
and the diffusion and invection
in two slightly different ways.
And machine one and one and take
the other as numerical.
And then you couple them
together, like maybe in a
differentiable end to end.
Yeah.
The, the reason I ask this is
because it does feel certainly
at least in the CFD community,
that there's a, there's a real
sort of split within the
community.
And in a sense that on one hand
you have people saying, well, we
have all these PDE solvers, you
know, developed for decades.
And you know what convinced me
how your machine learning or AI
method is going to be as good
and faster and cheaper versus on
the other hand, you have quite
sensational claims of, you know,
10,000 times faster, you know,
sort of real time.
Well, of course, when you dig
in, you know, you start asking
the questions, well, how much
data did you have?
What was the time to create the
data?
And but there is a bigger
question, I think more when you
look to the future, which is, is
it just a matter of time?
Is it a bit like in the 1980s,
they could only simulate a plane
to a reasonably low accuracy
because the computers just
weren't power enough.
And as you said, you just almost
keep the same effort almost.
And you just literally add 20
years of compute on top and now
you can simulate.
Or is it a we'll never get there
because we'll it's like an it's
like impossible to have that
much data?
This is the bit I think a lot of
BCS and start-ups are also
asking that question if we pump
100 million into this or a
billion, will we fix it?
Or is it a trillion dollar
problem and it's not worth
doing?
Yeah, Yeah.
I mean, OK.
So I think there's a there's a
bunch of things in the question
there.
Sorry.
We'll we'll CFD people to BC and
and you know that they have two
very different utility.
You.
Know, I think, OK, so it when
someone says to me do this,
convince me of that I have these
metrics that have been I've
worked on for decades, I just
say thank you, good to talk to
you.
I mean, because, because there's
no way you're going to win that
battle because they're very
fine-tuned metrics.
So they're very one little use
case.
Even if you do win that battle,
they're not going to admit it
because they'll, they'll tweak
their method and, and you know,
be slightly better than you.
And there's greener pastures few
everywhere.
And this is not a hypothetical
statement.
This is a very practical thing.
You're asking about this in the
context of PDS.
We saw this before in randomized
linear algebra.
I mean, so literally, I remember
it was very clear that the
techniques could potentially be
useful, not just in theory, but
in practice, and that the reason
the numerical people were
saying, oh, they won't work, You
know, really.
I mean, those are those number
of methods that clearly wouldn't
work.
But but then there's the next
generation of methods.
And that's sort of when I
entered the the area and it was
clear that they could
potentially work and the
objections people had before
wouldn't work.
And so this was right around the
time of the Blunden pic paper
that I mentioned that that
basically said, can you beat LA
pack?
And the short answer was yes.
So now, for example, if you look
at the Simon linear Alger
meeting, half the talks are on
this topic, but there's been
this process of creative
destruction where this they're
still asking the same questions,
but putting randomness there.
And so that's one group of
community.
I mean, a very different
community is the is the people
that say, I'm going to not do
that.
I'm going to go and apply it to
machine learning and 10 other
problems.
And, and, and so there's that
tension I was alluding to
before.
So I think if you, if you try
and, and satisfy an old school
metric, it's, it's good to have
a few examples of that as a
proof of principle.
And, and this is 15 years later,
and I mentioned it twice here,
right?
So this was a clear proof of
principle of the area.
The area sort of accelerated
after that.
And there's been a lot of theory
and empirical development.
So I think there's been a few
things that, if not that are
starting to look almost like
that in this general scientific
ML area.
I I think.
History is moving in that
direction.
So it's clear then that, you
know, randomness would be
important for linear algebra.
Now it's even more so for all
the historical and hardware
trends you were talking about.
I think likely the same thing's
going to happen here, right?
And so a question you could ask
is, are the people who know the
linear algebra, are the people
who know the computational fluid
dynamics?
Are they at the table developing
the methods?
Are they just going to Pooh,
Pooh it and say, well, they're
not going to work because it's
not going to satisfy my
particular measure as opposed to
here's a broad class of
techniques and it's hard to
imagine that there's nothing in
my area that will be improved by
them.
And so I think that's the that
that latter question is the
question to ask.
And that latter is the question
the questions VCs and and other
people will ask.
And I think the, an important
maybe determinant of how this
will evolve is, is how the
different players interact with
this in, in the sense that a lot
of the machine learning, more
broadly, scientific machine
learning, not just for the
foundation model, but more
broadly machine learning really
is, really is a horizontal.
I mean, it's, it's designed to
say, what can I do with lots of
data and be relatively ignorant
about your application area?
Because who knows why people
click on ads or click on links
on their social media account,
right?
I mean, you can tell the story,
but really who knows why?
And so a lot of machine learners
implicitly or explicitly will
say, I'm not interested in
solving your scientific problem
if it's just a one off problem.
I mean, if you're a scientist
using machine learning, you
might be interested in that, but
that's because you're interested
in the domain.
But if you're a machine learner,
you might say, I mean, I see
some commonalities between your
fluid dynamics and this other
solid mechanics problem.
And I see some similarities
there between that and something
in in 3DS in the atmosphere as
opposed to, you know, something
very different.
And so identifying those
commonalities I think is
important.
What I see in, in in some cases,
and this is Hanford by
universities and it's Hanford by
industry, and it's Hanford in a
couple government labs in, in a
couple different ways, is a lot
of people want to solve a
scientific problem.
And so they're going to say, I'm
only going to invest, invest
literally or figuratively in
machine learning in that one
area.
And that's just not how machine
learning works.
You don't see the, I mean, think
of it as horizontal business
with horizontals and verticals.
If machine learning is a
horizontal, like high
performance computing that will
solve a wide range of problems,
you got to apply it to a
vertical to justify it.
That's that's where that that's
where you know, the rubber hits
the road typically.
And so you don't see the
successes in machine learning,
scientific machine learning at
vertical companies, you know,
companies working in genetics or
or oil exploration or any of a
range of other particular domain
verticals.
You see it in the horizontal
companies.
The companies have built out the
technology infrastructure and
they get a team of people that
know this is a vertical and
applies it there.
And then, you know, a team that
knows a different vertical and
applies it there.
And so I think the question is,
how does that play out?
And that's going to be a non
trivial evolution in terms of.
And your.
That day.
Your comment was interesting as
well about the difference
between sort of Transformers
versus CNNS and you know, if you
just throw the whole world's
Internet at CNN, that isn't you
needed to have the right
architecture to be able to throw
a lot of data at it.
I guess the question is more for
the science.
Is there a common architecture
across the sciences that then
would allow you to sort of build
out that big which could be
applied to verticals?
Or is it the case that the needs
for weather or genetics or
chemistry are so different that
you would need a different
architecture for for each
different size?
And therefore the, the, the
dream of a true foundational
thing.
Besides, it will never happen
because you know.
Yeah.
So that's the big question.
And I, I think there's a
technical component to that and
then non-technical component in
terms of the areas, right?
And so technically it's
open-ended.
I don't know, right?
I mean, we're, we're in the
middle of the fray and we're,
we're voting with our feet and
placing a bet there that the,
that the answer is or could be
yes.
To try and address that, you're
going to have to deal with the
issues we were talking about
before.
You know, one dimension is very,
very special. 2 dimension, the
surface area to volume
properties are very different. 3
dimensions is very different.
By the time you get 4 in
scientific computing, that's
sort of infinite, right?
Machine learners, by the time
until you get to a million, you
know, it still seems pretty
small.
So mapping the methods to one
versus 2 versus 3 dimensions,
open question, maybe there'll be
no trade off point where the
surface area to volume and the
isoperimetry and other things
like that wins.
I suspect not.
I suspect it could, but I mean,
open question.
And then non technically, if you
look at how computer science
evolved, numerical analysis and
scientific computing was core to
computer science.
Look at how numerical analysis
and computer science evolved.
Yeah, these areas gave birth to
computer science and then
computer science banished them
because it was easier to build
the structure, the theory
around, around Turing machines
and, and, and the Lambda
calculus and, and discreet
notions that talked about
complexity independent of the
data.
And if you're talking about
complexity independent of the
data, you don't need
preconditioners because it's
independent of the data.
And so there's a cultural aspect
that that says, you know, does
the vertical or the horizontal
culture win here?
And so even if you stipulate
that the answer is technically
yes, I think there's an open
question on how it'll look,
it'll evolve and whether that'll
win the day and solve the
problems that you're asking.
But I think it's not, it's not
so much that I solved PDE type A
and applied it to PDE type B.
It would be certain course
things.
I mean, as you know, there's a
class of things for which finite
element methods work.
There's a different class of
things for which finite volume
methods work.
And you know, you, you take a
course, you learn A1 O1 method
and then boom, they bifurcate
after that.
So what's the analogous taxonomy
here?
And it's probably neither of
those.
It's probably something that's
more data-driven, but what's the
right way to taxonomize that?
And even if there's a
technically a correct way, I
mean, you know, computer science
is not computational science.
Computer science is an area of
the coherent.
Computational science is spread
over many departments and many
divisions.
And so I think it's an open
question about how this area
evolves.
Yeah, it is certainly.
It is certainly interesting.
I think one of the sort of key
topics to all of this though is
the data availability and
licensing and financial reward.
So one thing that I've seen in I
guess the early days is nobody
knew what was going on.
So I guess the companies were
scraping half the Internet.
There were a few captures or
there was a few sort of, you
know, firewalls to stop thing.
But in general, it was a sort of
free for all it seemed, Whereas
now people have, you know,
cottoned on to that and some of
the companies having to do deals
with publishing companies or do
deals with, you know, to try and
legally get access or or
permissively get access to
things.
I saw the example on the weather
side that, you know, some of
those databases were released
openly because they were
released openly enabled, you
know, these various teams to go
and do things like, you know,
forecast net and graph cast.
But those data may not be open
in the future.
So how much you know, and you
work in academia, you see people
want to have their own data.
Some people want to release
later.
Do you see that that will
ultimately be the blocker?
I mean, how do you incentivize
people to want to make their
data available and should it
even be done that way, you know,
that the whole open source data
versus closed?
You know, this is this, I think,
is the elephant in the room in
terms of this area because a lot
of government grants require
that you make the data publicly
available in some sense of the
word.
Now, what does in some sense of
the word mean for a lot of
scientists?
If the data is more than a year
or two old, it's worthless
because they're trying to push
the cutting edge of the science
and then they don't maintain the
data for more than a couple
years ago.
And so no one maintains and it's
hard to access.
So there's a lot of public data
that's not de facto public or
accessible, you know, in a lot
in those cases and maybe in, in,
but, but certainly in, in
machine learning sort of
applications more generally in,
in Internet and social media and
so on.
Having older data is good, but
you can't get more than a couple
decades older, right?
And so often times the the most
recent data is the most valuable
and you just design A method
around that.
And so it's not obvious to me
that the way the data are
generated and, and collected,
distributed now will be the one
that is going developed going
forward.
I mean, if you get better
telescopes, if you get better,
you know, molecular sort of
robotic systems to, to to make
molecules, I can easily imagine
a situation where data that
exists now or prior to a few
years ago is basically obsolete
and irrelevant.
And so all of that data sits at
whoever generated it.
And so then the question is, is
does a government lab generate
it?
And if so, do they make it easy
de facto to access?
Is it done at universities
where, you know, you have a big
infrastructure capital
investment in in particular,
essentially in particular
science and verticals to
generate it?
Is it done at companies that are
in different verticals or is
there some sort of collaboration
or interaction with, you know,
horizontal infrastructure
companies, hyper scalers and
then they get their fingers in
that and have access to it?
So I think these are all open
questions in in terms of how
this evolves.
Yeah, it it seems to be very
much, you know, traditionally
and I guess if this is for me,
the difference between the pre
trained quote quote foundation
models versus just letting
someone go and train them.
Although I mean, I guess most
people you and I would not go
and train our own LLM.
We're just going to go and use
someone who's audit and we're
just doing an inference on it.
That's and I could see if I'm
BMW and I have data from
previous car designs or
simulations or whatever, how
they could train a model using
their data.
But I'm sort of wondering in my
head, how could it ever become
the point where some person has
access to not only BM WS data,
but Fords and Audi's and Volvos
and Boeings and Airbuses and you
know, Exxon Mobil and Shell and
everyone else.
Like how how could they collect
the data?
What would be the incentive for
that to happen to or that's what
I mean.
Or is it the case that that's
why there will never be a
foundation and it will just be
that individual people train
their own models because the
data is just so sensitive and
difficult to collect in one?
Yeah.
I mean, this is, I think this is
the big elephant in the room.
I mean, it's not clear to me
that one.
OK.
So I think if you were to try
and generate a meaningful
scientific foundation model,
you'd need data from a pretty
broad range of use cases.
And so you gave, you know,
several that in particular are
with is a strong sort of
financial backing.
I'm always reminded of the
story.
Gray was, I guess, the most
prominent person in the
Microsoft's research division
years ago, such that, you know,
he would have to have regular
meetings with Bill Gates, the
CEO at the time.
And Bill Gates would say, why is
the most prominent person in my
research division applying
databases techniques to
astronomy?
This is when he started working
with Alex Silly and some others
on, on databases for, for
astronomy and, and cosmology.
Why don't you work on something
more useful like, you know, any
of our products?
And, and crazy answer was
basically, I'm working on it
because it's worthless, because
there's no financial sort of
incentive behind it.
I don't have to talk to the
lawyers and we can work at IP
and all these things.
It's public data and, and I can
work on database techniques and
figure out latency and bandwidth
and all these trade-offs.
So I don't know, but it would be
interesting to see.
Will you have an analogous thing
here?
So there's there, there is
public, there's, there's various
places where public data is
available.
And I think if you can
illustrate that you would have a
proof of principle foundation
like model.
Then the question is, will
people come to it?
Now clearly the incentives for
scientists will be different
than than for companies there.
But I could imagine a situation
where you build that out and
then companies could take it and
fine tune to their particular
data, right.
It's not obvious to me that any
of the companies that you
mentioned have data that that's,
that is that special in a
scientific sense?
I mean, clearly the particular
data they have is particular to
their particular situation and
then the particular, you know,
product they have.
But I, I can imagine that, you
know, the Pdes from early solar
system formation and, and
hydrogen bomb explosions and
hydrodynamics inside stars, you
know, is, has some similarities
and some differences with
weather and climate and some
similarities and some
differences with crack
propagation in the Earth.
And that'll have some
similarities and differences
with, with various sorts of
sensing modalities that you
would, that have a geospatial
component.
And so can you stress test that
and, and get even even a proof
of principle that, that if you
would attack those on, then the
answer would be yes, that, that
you could have a path to have a
more foundation model.
If the answer is yes, then the
question is you talk to various
stakeholders.
Some of them are government
entities or government sponsors,
some of them are corporate and
try and figure that out.
And I could, I could imagine
that that basically it's too big
a left in the area stalls.
So I think this is something to
be determined.
But I think having a nucleus of
something is going to be
important because right now I at
least what I've seen, I mean, in
most of companies like that,
there's, there's, there may be
some people a little bit
intrigued, but there's not a
sufficiently heavy lift that
they go screaming at their CEO
to say we need to do this,
probably because it's not
extremely strong baselines that
it can happen.
And their competitors by talking
to these public models and fine
tuning on their proprietary data
will do better.
I think at that point they'll be
you can see a change.
And I think this is, I mean, I
guess this is affecting the
current Gen.
AI and AI, which is how do you
make money out of this?
You know, like you can do it for
the sake of science.
That's nice.
I developed this thing.
But I'm always interested to see
like the money that you put in
to create the data to train the
model, can you ultimately make a
profitable thing out of it that
justifies its cost?
Now, with standard, I guess,
simulation software, there's an
argument, well, if I simulate
it, I don't have to build it.
If I can predict the weather, I
can help people figure out if
it's there's going to be a
hurricane.
And I can say, you know, there's
a, there's a clear thing.
But because we can already
simulate things, we can already
predict the weather.
We can always do it.
For me, the machine learning bit
is just the argument, well, it's
faster or, or, or it's cheaper.
That's where the amount of data
do.
Do you know what I mean?
Is there a commercial?
But I, I think, I think there's
a faster question and I think
it's tempting to say, can I be
faster?
Because faster means there's a
number you're comparing to.
So am I bigger?
Am I more on some axis?
And back to the, the, the
randomized linear algebra
example, I mean, I, I was
talking to various people and
saying, don't worry about the
randomness.
You know, if, if you do this and
that, that'll work.
And the people would, you know,
basically when you have a new
idea, they'll beat you up.
And so they beat us up and so
on.
And a few years later, one of
those people in particular had
some methods and showed it
worked, you know, not the blend
people, you know, something
around the same time and their
students came back to me and
didn't know who I was.
I was lecturing me and saying,
oh, don't worry about the
randomness, it'll all be fine.
And so on.
There's just a cultural shift.
And so there was a cultural
shift that really was not, is as
faster as this is as better.
And so I, I, I don't think
you're going to see the win here
just because something's faster
and better.
You might need that to point to,
but the win will happen because
you can solve other things that
you couldn't solve before.
So just as an example, say
you're, you know, you want a
better battery and you want to
understand the way crack
propagates better, you know, so
that I mean, you want, you want,
you want a longer lifetime, you
know, warranty.
So you, you're working on
developing batteries.
One of the ways this fits in,
not in a scientific, but in an
engineering or commercial
context is you want to write a
warranty to say that that the
batteries are going to last so
and so long.
And, and otherwise you'll, you
know, you'll eat the cost.
And so can you predict battery
lifetimes.
And maybe if you have a certain
crack propagation heterogeneity
structure, you know that it
correlates better with how long
the batteries will last.
So now there's a fair
variability and a particular run
on the extreme tails.
So that sounds sort of very
different than I want to do oil
exploration and better fracking
or something.
I send sound waves down into the
earth and I look at how they
bounce back and I try and learn
something about it.
But I could imagine that the
embeddings that you get from a
core model that cuts across a
couple different domains learn
spatiotemporal properties in
particular of complex systems
that have sort of long ranged,
non trivial, heavy tailed
correlations, which is what both
of those examples have.
And so say that you can come up
with a model that captures those
embeddings.
Now, a company here may tweak it
to their data, do some transfer
learning in the battery space.
A company over here can do a
better job adjusting it to their
data, which is, you know,
spatiotemporally very different
in terms of, you know, better
fracking.
And, you know, for all I know,
the same embeddings could be
useful for, you know, you had a
very different use case, right?
And certainly in the United
States, there's various places
where insurance markets don't
exist for floods or for
earthquakes or for a range of
things like that.
I could imagine that you get
these course embeddings.
These are course functions.
They're not sinusoids and 4:00
AM modes.
They're something that's
data-driven embeddings.
And you say on top of that, I
want to do transfer learning to
the relatively small amount of
data that I have.
That's very high touch.
You know, you have 10,000
stations across the country that
measure something in chemicals,
whatever I want to do transfer
learning to that and I model,
you know, model the system, the
way information flows in the
Mississippi Delta or something.
And, and if I do that, I can do
a better job, you know,
predicting the tails of flood
events.
Why?
Because as a model, I don't know
how things propagate, but you
know, subtle effects in terms of
the density of the soil or, or
the moisture of the soil coupled
with, you know, 10,000 other
things that the neural network
learns in a complicated way.
What's hard to reason about
scientifically means that now I
can create that market.
And that's, that's something
that any of those companies I
could imagine try and you know,
buy out a start up company that
does that.
So I think you're going to see a
win.
Not just I'm running faster,
something faster than you, but
but in a space like that.
Yeah, no, I, I, I think what
you're getting at is you, what
we've seen from current machine
that it seems to do things that
we don't fully understand, but
are like you, like you gave the
original example of the time
series that an LM that wasn't
explicitly trained on it
actually ended up being quite
useful.
So I guess we shouldn't
underestimate the potential of
how some of these things may do
something that we're, it's not
just about replicating what an
existing simulation tool could
do, but maybe it could help to
merge different disciplines
together and see the links and
the, and the, and the things
between them.
I did want to pivot to a
different topic, which is when
some of the other people I've
spoken to, I'm always really
fascinated by the curiosity or
the uniqueness or the
peculiarity of academia and, and
the sort of different people's
careers and, and, and
progression through.
And I think you have quite an
interesting one, because you are
a very pure.
Mathematician, academic, you
know, you, you are very much in
that, but you also have, you
know, the Amazon scholar
position you at the, you know,
Lawrence Berkeley.
Was this a a strategic thing in
the sense that you wanted to
work on real problems?
Was this a just you find more
interesting, like is there, How
has it benefited you?
And would you advise it to
others?
You know?
Yeah.
I mean, it's there's a lot of,
again, a lot of questions.
I mean, at least the narrow
questions, universities versus
not, yeah.
Yeah, there you go.
I'll start.
That but, but, but yeah, you
tapped enough stuff into the
question to make it Ford
compatible with lots of answers
as it sounds like.
I mean, so my, my, you know, OK,
so my PF2's in physics, I never
actually studied computer
science or statistics.
And it was in computational
statistical mechanics.
And at the end of the
dissertation I switched areas
basically to theoretical
computer science to work on
originally Markov chain
algorithms, some of the stuff
I've been working on
computationally, Markov chains
and molecular dynamics.
So it was a technical
connection, but it was it was
fairly loose.
And then the randomization
inside the Markov chains that
the people I was working with
were also working on these very
early versions of these
randomized linear algebra
algorithms.
So I got involved with that and
I'd done enough coding that was
clear certain ones are going to
be useful and certain ones
weren't.
And so at that point I decided
to switch areas partly because
of what I've been working on.
Well, two reasons there was a
forcing function.
This is I just mentioned this
because if you have younger
people listening, it's good to
know that sometimes older people
have had textured past, let's
say.
So Long story short, I had
career ending problems with the
dissertation advisor and and the
supply demand structure in the
natural sciences and engineering
is very different than in
computer science.
And so that was was motivation
to, you know, jump off the
Cliff.
I also realized that that the
particular work I've been doing
in computational system
mechanics, this is a great area.
I loved it and and it's informed
a lot of the stuff that I've
done since then.
But you know, it was a great
area to be in a 1970 because you
know, Ford compatible with a
huge expansion.
There's going to be Nobel prizes
given out.
I mean, just lots of good stuff
going on.
Not so much in 2000.
The area, it's sort of sad, but
it was clear that that the
future is going to be data
analysis and, and I joke that I
never knew more about algorithms
or data than the day I switched.
And then I've just been becoming
more ignorant since then.
So I don't know quite what I
meant by data analysis then, but
but but clearly I was right.
I mean, it was a fruitful area
for the next couple decades.
So I done work in theory of
algorithms and, and with respect
to the academic question, if
you're desperately wed to an
academic career, you shouldn't
do this because the academic
hiring is fairly siloed and, and
it's, it's not a good idea to
switch areas after your
dissertation and, and so on.
If, if you, if there's a forcing
function like I had, or you're
interested in sort of problems
more broadly, then you can think
a little bit more broadly.
So I've had a lot of students in
postdocs and I sort of give them
this advice and you try and
carve out various projects that
they're interested in.
Some want an academic route, so
they should work on slightly
more conservative things in the
general space.
Some definitely 1 industry and
some, you know, could go with
either and, and the ones that
could go with either, I've seen
some go one way and some go the
other.
As a general rule, this is going
to be a marketable space and
stuff I do.
And so maybe it's a little bit
less of an issue, but but, but
that's something that they
figure out.
So I had done work in in
theoretical computer science and
it was clear that these
algorithms would be useful more
broadly because the randomness
entered in a very different way
then classical algorithms.
And so then the question is, how
does it evolve?
And so it evolved.
I was at Yale in the mathematics
department as in one of the
junior faculty positions.
I spent time at Yahoo and
Stanford and moved to Berkeley.
I'm in the statistics department
there and at the International
Computer Science Institute of
Lawrence Berkeley National Lab.
And as you mentioned couple
years ago started with as an
Amazon scholar working in the
supply chain optimization
technology group, where, you
know, we work on better
forecasting, demand forecasting
algorithms and supply chain
decisions.
So I think this is, this is
something that's good for people
to think about.
And you know, there's at least,
I guess 4 hats there.
And each hat has pros and cons
and pluses and minuses.
And so figuring out how to
navigate that space is something
I try and encourage students and
post docs to think about sooner
rather than later.
How?
How much should people expect to
have to move?
You know, I always think this is
1 of this sad in a way, things
about academia, at least from
what I've observed, that the
fact that you do your PhD and
let's say you do a postdoc, how
realistic is it that that person
in the US or the UK should
assume that they can stay at
that same university and just
move up a chain?
Or how much should they expect
that they're basically going to
have to move somewhere else in
the country to find the
position?
Yeah.
I mean, the short answer is that
when you do a postdoc, it's
usually more targeted because
you're working with a particular
person, a particular group and
and so you could be at the same
place or not.
It's usually a good idea to go
elsewhere to get experience with
other people, the real filters
at the assistant professor
level.
And you got to move there
because, you know, except in our
cases, you don't get a job at
the same place.
And that's not a statement about
whether the place where you are
at is good or bad or whether
you're good or bad is just just
run the numbers, right.
If there's 10:20, 30-40 places
hiring and that you're looking
at and and the chances are one
and whatever that that you get
an offer, it's just unlikely to
happen at that same place even
if ultimately end up there.
Sometimes people go and leave
and come back.
So moving for better for us as
part of the part of the
equation, yeah.
But did you, some of the
questions I get is the should
they go into industry or, or
just let's put this two ways,
does academia value industry?
So if you've been an assistant
professor or you've been a
postdoc and you then say, you
know what, I'm going to go into
industry, do they value then?
And is the ability to come back
or have you been out of the game
too long?
You haven't sort of, you know,
got the publications or the
teaching experience, You know,
is that a good piece of advice
or would you say no, no, no, If
you really want to be an
academia, you basically need to
stay in in academia.
Yeah, I mean it, it's, it's more
texture than the following.
But I, I think the short answer
is that that that you need to
stay.
The slightly longer answer is it
depends on the area, like
computer science versus
statistics versus engineering
are rather different.
In some cases having a startup,
in some cases having a postdoc
in industry is good and you can
go back to universities and that
tends to correlate with computer
science.
I don't know as much in
engineering that may be changing
over time, but less so.
And maybe statistics and applied
math.
I think in a sense, on the one
hand, people value the
experience you might have, but
not really.
And by that I mean, you know,
if, if you, if you check all, if
if you check all my boxes.
And in addition, you have this
other stuff, good, but you got
to check all my boxes and the
boxes are the things you alluded
to.
And so there's sometimes there's
post docs that at industry that
are basically academic post
docs, you write papers.
So I'm not counting that because
that's, that's the fact of the
same sort of thing.
But if you're out more than a
couple years and you have fewer
papers, it just gets harder to
publish.
There are certainly cases where
people do that, especially if
they have some high profile ones
and, and can work their way back
one way or the other.
But it's, you know, you should
know going in that you're, it's
like a salmon swimming upstream.
And this is going to be a hard
one.
So how does he, this is maybe
people in the US are maybe a
little bit more familiar, but
particularly people who are not.
So how does it work with the
national labs?
So you have a position on the
national labs.
How, how does that work between
is this a, a quite common thing
in a way for these things to
happen?
I I can only imagine how you
juggle the e-mail inboxes and
the sort of meetings, but I
guess it's valuable.
And interesting off an hour
today and I haven't been hit by
e-mail.
That's what I've turned it off.
That's the accept e-mail is a
little overwhelming.
I mean, it's not so common.
So, so I, I with the Berkeley
hack, because I'm in the
statistic department there, I'm
at Lawrence Berkeley lab.
It's literally just up the hill.
And so I can, you can walk
there.
And so they worked in scientific
machine learning and, and I had
done work and was well known in
machine learning and, and
algorithms and statistics, large
scale statistics.
And I had various projects over
the years with people there and
elsewhere on scientific ML
problems.
And so started about two years
ago.
This is all we rename, but the
scientific machine learning
group, basically MLA machine
learning and analytics.
And and so it's it's it's part
was partly facilitating for the
fact that there there is a
moderate amount of interaction
between UC Berkeley campus and
LBNL Lawrence Berkeley National
Lab, Oak Ridge Argon.
Some of the other labs have
things like that, but it's not
so, so, so common.
Most people are there, meaning
just there and 100% of their FT
ES there and and there for long
term but so it's not.
I wouldn't say it's very common.
OK, which makes your experience
even more unique then to have
done it.
Yeah, what maybe is a sort of
finishing off comment or, or
topic is if you have somebody
now who was wanting to get into
scientific machine learning,
because this is I guess kind of
what we've been largely talking
about, what would you get them
to focus on?
They're doing a PhD or they're
doing a postdoc.
But is there any, doesn't have
to be a very, you know, Pacific,
Pacific, but what sort of area
we'd say, you know, this is
something you should look at.
This is an area that is ripe
for, you know, progress.
Yeah, that's a good question.
There's certain things, I mean,
that are less ripe for progress
in scientific ML, even if
they're important scientific
problems.
So what I, what I, what I would
try and say is work.
You should work on a problem
that's of interest to both
sides.
Otherwise you're coming at it
from one side or another.
And this is true whether you're
coming from CS or stats learning
scientific problems are coming
from one scientific area.
You should work on trying to
figure out how to frame what
you're doing as something of
interest to both sides.
So I have projects that, you
know, we, we, we construct
projects, you know, student, a
postdoc owns a piece of it.
And, and a goal typically is we
want a publication in the
particular scientific area, but
also in an ML venue.
And it need to be the same one.
Sometimes it is, it's a long
version, a short version.
Sometimes it's just two
different things, but work on a
method that's broad enough that
machine learning people are
interested in it and that by the
definition of machine learning,
people are interested.
You convince 3 reviewers to say
yes.
And so it's an imperfect
process, you know the review
process, etcetera, but boom, you
get it in a top machine learning
band room.
And similarly, on the scientific
side, you know, a, a statement
that it's a value of the
scientist is you get 3 reviewers
to say accept and then it's
accepted on the scientific side.
And oftentimes the way we try
and scope our projects is to
say, you know, we don't on the
machine learning side, we don't
want to work on your problem if
it's only of interest to you.
If I can't apply it to some
other area, someone else, some
other domain, Because if that's
the case, I probably need to
know so much about your area
that I become, you know, an
expert in your particular area.
And similarly, on the scientific
side, you know, if you have a
particular method that is only
that's so heavily tailored to
your domain that it's not going
to be useful more broadly to
machine learning people, that's
a much harder sell.
Then you're not doing something
that satisfies both sides.
So something that I knew about
from working on years ago was
like sequence alignment in in
genetics, right?
Clearly an important problem,
not something that's portable
the particular album, not
something that's portable to
lots of other scientific areas,
but better machine learning
methods for solving
spatiotemporal forecasting
problems with non trivial
boundary constraints.
That's clearly of interest to a
pretty wide range of
applications.
And also to solve it, you're
going to have to introduce
technical solutions that are
probably, you know, go, can you
come up with a differential
optimizer for an end to end
differentiable system where you
have hard constraints?
I mean, that's clearly something
of interest to machine learning
and optimization.
So I guess I'd try and focus on
something there.
And that is probably the way
that you're going to be.
And unless you know exactly what
you want to be doing 30 years
from now, that's probably the
way to make yourself most
forward compatible with with
however.
That's a really, that's a really
good point.
I guess what you're saying is,
yeah, it's true.
Like later on in your career
you've become established in a
certain area, but most people
during their PhD or the postdoc
at that time have no real
necessary idea.
So you're saying if you do
something broad enough that can
get you exposed to different
groups and and have a foundation
to your earlier comment, you can
more easily go into verticals
because you've built that
foundation.
Whereas I guess if you jump
directly into a vertical right
from the beginning for you to
sort of reverse out that it's
kind of harder, isn't it?
So I I think that's what you're
alluding to it, it sets you up
better.
Yeah, yeah, because it's not at
all.
I mean, all the questions you're
asking are fair ones.
And it's not at all clear how
the whole area will evolve.
And so depending on how it
evolves, having experience in
one versus another.
And, and I think I mean, having
worked in a bunch of areas, you
know, it's, it's, but, but
speaking substantially only
English, but a but a little bit
of other things I can imagine.
And I see, you know, you learn a
second language, it's hard.
You learn a third language, the,
the relative cost is a lot less.
You learn a fourth.
I mean, so there's a diminishing
returns in terms of the amount
of extra effort you need to do.
So you work in one area, switch
to the second.
It's very hard switch to the
third.
You know, you can, you know, you
can, you can do that.
And after that, one thing I've
sort of been always struck by is
it's amazing how little you, you
need to know about a particular
area, especially if you're
working with good people who'll
complement what you're doing.
You can learn from them, right?
And so it's amazing what you
don't need to know in order to,
to get interesting results in an
area.
And so, and so being learning
new things.
By the time you know two or
three things, it's easy to learn
the 4th.
Yeah, yeah, I know that that
makes sense.
Well, thank you so much.
I it's the day after Labour Day,
which means that probably
there's a whole bunch of emails
and stuff that's started to come
through on essentially your
first day back.
And I know we probably could
have carried on for for another
couple of hours.
But yeah, thank you.
Really, really appreciate it and
look forward to catching up in
person at some conference in the
future.
Sounds great, thanks for having
me, this has been fun.
All right.
Cheers.
None.